It is 9:45 AM we are picking up another passenger on this extremely long road to
who will Ohio.
Um,
if it gets longer by the minute,
there was actually a guy before you who was a passenger and we were blogging him
and then he's like,
can you guys cut the shit out?
So we just were quiet for 30 minutes and we didn't say anything.
You're wondering why are you so annoyed sir?
Then he ended up in an accountant office and we understood 15 minutes to get to
the shoreline amphitheater but it's very close by.
It's just the fact that the traffic is so massive.
That's the road you got to save for the journey.
Walking to Google io.
Uh,
this is mountain view,
California and there's a lot of traffic here by,
it's going to be good.
We are here at Google io.
This is huge and everything is here.
Everybody is here.
I'm sure I'd go,
what's your name and part of what brings you to Google io?
I'm an android developer.
I got to learn the latest and greatest stuff to work on.
Damn.
Stuart Fried.
I head up the scholarships team,
Udacity and it's about connecting people with opportunities they might not
otherwise have.
Yeah.
This is my first year here at this amazing opening.
Was
excited about the future and what's coming soon.
Show mark court work on the actual actions.
Marco.
Hey,
I'm Alice.
I also work on it and Google Assistant.
Hey,
I'm out of all on what kind of student assessment?
Just like the other two and one thing you're most excited about about Google io
this year.
Meaning all the many people,
many different developers along the work.
Yeah,
I'm excited about the developers that came from really far away that are
building totally innovative ways we hadn't thought about,
especially with the new machine learning.
Yeah.
Getting all the feedback from so many developers all around the world.
So three to Excite Dr. Oh great.
Thanks.
Thanks guys.
Okay.
Can I ask you a question about Google io?
I can so far here.
Okay.
But there's so many core people here from all over the world,
and it says one of those places where you come and you feel,
you understand your talk,
you eat,
you watch keynote.
This is the place to be.
So if you want to go to a conference,
you got to go to w I.
L I'm having a great time here.
Alrighty.
Here on entering Google io is that android
things?
A lot of stuff here that,
there is a lot of stuff here.
These look really cool.
What are these?
Yeah,
these are like machine learning flowers.
If you actually look right in the camera,
the camera's x.
You're filming your facial expression.
So if you look at it and smiles
for if you frown.
So this is Manny,
Manny the hand by who has bill using Andrea things,
bass kit with a whole bunch of accessories.
We have used a tensor flow model to teach gestures to this guy so that it can
identify what you're actually doing.
UNCANNY,
right?
Resemblance
brother now.
Yeah.